tim is fighting back after she was
attacked for posting a nude selfie and
she would double down by posting another
one today well we talked to one of Kim's
critics Piers Morgan now woke up this
morning to find all hell breaking loose
on my Twitter feed piers in London with
us today on the defensive it all started
yesterday after Kim posted this with a
caption when you're like I have nothing
to wear lol I suggested to Kim I will
happily step in and buy you some clothes
Kim had responded by inferring that I
should stay off Ashley Madison the
cheating website because it's the kind
of activity they do on their in
offerings by married women clothes Kim
then at a new nude and hashtag did
liberated I don't think this is very
liberating
you're a 35 year old mother of two very
young children a little desperate some
stars seem to be team Kim anti peers
including Ariel winter abigail breslin
and his entourage co-star Emily
Ratajkowski today the blurred lines
video vixen posted quote love when a man
comments on a woman's decision to post a
nude photo her body her career sex is
blank really why can't men comment about
this